[Musique]
bonjour tan Mohamed swali merci beaucoup
merci d'être avec nous nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu de Mayotte memb du Group r des
pays ce sont les sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle on va évidemment
revenir sur la situation à Mayotte sur
les attentes des élus ultramarins mais
d'abord un mot un mot on l'a vu dans le
journal sur la situation en Israël et à
Gaza la France qui pourrait accueillir
des enfants blessés ou des malades de
Gaza pour y être soigné et Emmanuel
Macron qui interpelle Benyamin
netaniaahou sur le trop grand nombre de
victimes civiles et qui estime qu'il
faut obtenir une trêve humanitaire
est-ce qu'il peut être entendu alors que
Benjamin netanahou rejette toute idée de
trêve et de cesser le feu le président
de la République est dans dans son rôle
je dirais la France est dans son rôle ce
rôle d'équilibre entre d'une part
condamner fermement le le terrorisme et
les actes du Hamas et de l'autre côté
appelé à à de l'humanité
ce sont des bébés ce sont des enfants
qui n'ont rien demandé à personne et il
est légitime que le Président de la
République déploie tous ses efforts pour
que ces ces innocents ces civiles ne ne
soit ne soi pas ne soi pas davantage
davantage tué mais est-ce qu'elle est
pas en train d'évoluer la ligne du
président de la République parce qu'au
début il affichait un soutien très clair
à Israël là il interpelle benjamine
netaniaahou sur un trop grand nombre de
victimes il demande à cesser le feu
alors qu'il sait que Benjamin netanahou
n'en veut pas est-ce que la ligne de la
France devient pas complètement isible
ceux qui voient une ligne qui bouge
vraiment je je m'en étonne parce que
tout ce que vous avez dit n'est pas
contradictoire euh la France est l'ami
de l'État d'Israël l'Israël l'ami de
l'état de de la France et c'est ce qui a
été précisé au début ceci n'est pas
incompatible avec le fait d'en appeler
aux règles internationales humanitaires
de protection des des civils et moi je
ne vois pas la contradiction ni le le le
mouvement dans la ligne de la de la
France on va parler d'un autre sujet
vendredi se tenaient les rencontres de
Saint- Emmanuel Macron a a appelé les
chefs de partis à dialoguer sur
plusieurs sujets notamment sur la
question de l'élargissement du
référendum et à la sortie de ces
réunions on a appris que finalement le
chef de l'État a renonçait à un
référendum sur l'immigration pourquoi ne
pas donner la parole au français sur ce
sujet alors le le le sujet et est
complexe quelle question allons-nous
poser le cas échéant à la à la
population euh c'est un
sujet qui est suffisamment compliqué
pour en faire une question alors c'est
vrai que euh le le le peuple on pe on
peut dire le peuple qui qui se prononce
directement sur une question aussi aussi
cruciale ça peut paraître séduisant mais
l'immigration est c'est ça la
particularité des des lois qui sont
intervenues ces dernières années c'est
que ce sont des lois qui ont dû
s'adapter à une situation mouvante
d'année d'année en année
et mais comme beaucoup de sujets parce
qu'Emmanuel Macron il veut élargir le
champ du référendum au aux questions de
société est-ce que ces questions ne sont
pas compliquées c'est plus simple de
faire un référendum sur la fin de vie
par exemple euh oui parce que là là la
question qui va être posée est moins
mouvante et moins complexe que pour la
question de de l'immigration qui dépend
de beaucoup de choses et notamment des
situations de guerre notamment des des
déplace des déplacements des population
des populations qui souffrent
euh ce sujet n'est pas mû euh
suffisamment mû pour faire l'objet euh
d'un d'un référendum où il faut un large
consensus ce n'est pas comme les
majorités habituelles au sein des des
assemblées c'est un consensus enfin un
une majorité plus large et et euh il
n'est pas sur mur pour en faire une
question référendaire sur la question de
l'immigration le Sénat a durci le projet
de loi du gouvernement la majorité
sénatoriale de la de la droite et du
centre est-ce qu'il y a des dispositions
que vous souhaitez voir garder à
l'Assemblée nationale par les députés de
la majorité et par le gouvernement vous
savez je suis toujours partagé entre la
situation migratoire euh du pays en en
général euh et celle de mon département
qui qui est insupportable euh PL la
plupart des mesures qui sont euh dans
dans le texte euh méritent d'être gardé
par l'Assemblée nationale sauf celle qui
concerne l'aide médicale euh d'État par
exemple mais les autres oui par exemple
sur la réécriture de l'article 3 sur les
métiers en tension tel que le Sénat l'
réécrit ça vous convient moi ça me
convient euh et et d'ailleurs euh sur ce
sujet une une disposition réglementaire
aurait aura aurait pu suffire
euh si la rédaction change un tout un
tout petit peu par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé à la au Sénat pourquoi pas
mais moi sur le principe ça me ça me
convient on va continuer à parler de ce
sujet et particulièrement dans votre
territoire on va parler de la situation
à Mayotte il y a plusieurs semaines
Gérald harmanin lancé une opération pour
détruire les bidonsville et freiner
l'immigration illégale alors où en
est-on de cette opération wambouchou
réponse avec Alexandre
[Musique]
pard bonjour Alex bonjour ARANE bonjour
tan Mohamed soli bonjour et Alex au
printemps dernier le gouvernement a donc
lancé l'opération wambouchou une
opération de grande empleur pour lancer
lutter contre l'immigration clandestine
l'imbita insalubre et l'insécurité quel
bilan peut-on en faire plus de 6 mois
plus tard et bien cette opération a
apporté des résultats mais sans
forcément atteindre tous ses objectifs
par exemple sur la lutte contre le
logement insaluble le gouvernement avait
pour but de détruire 1000 cases de
bidonville et en septembre dernier 400
avaient été été au final détruit surous
le pilotage de la préfecture le problème
sur ce sujet c'est qu'il manque des
solutions de relogement pour les
habitants qui souhaitaient quitter ces
bidonville donc certaines personnes se
sont juste déplacées vers d'autres
habitats insalubres ensuite sur la lutte
contre l'insécurité à Mayotte le
ministre de l'Intérieur géralde de
Darmanin a donné quelques chiffres en
septembre dernier depuis le début de
l'opération wambouchou les nombreuses
forces de l'ordre mobilisé sur le
terrain ont réalisé plus de 1300
interpellations dont la cinquantaine de
chefs de gangue qui sévissaient sur ce
territoire le nombre de violence sur les
personnes a baissé de 10 % notamment les
vols avec violence et puis l'autre
objectif c'était la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine venue des îles
des Comores voisines ambouchou a permis
d'accélérer les expulsions avec une
moyenne de 70 expulsions par jour
auparavant on était plutôt sur 70
expulsions tous les 3 jours et grâce à
la mobilisation des magistrats le
tribunal administratif a indiqué que le
nombre de dossiers de contentieux des é
étranger avait baissé de 34 %. et Alex
quelles sont les réactions face au
premier résultats de l'opération et bien
elles sont plutôt mitigées parmi les
élus la droite estime que cela ne va pas
assez loin la gauche aurait préféré que
ces moyens soient utilisés pour résoudre
la crise de l'eau mais certains élus qui
d'ailleurs ne sont pas forcément
macronist sont quand même satisfait de
cette opération c'est le cas de la
députée de Mayotte membre du groupe
lyott à l'Assemblée nationale le groupe
liberté indépendant outreemire et
territoire Estelle Youssoufa je la cite
wambouchou a fait comprendre à l'état
que la situation de de Mayotte n'était
pas inextricable dès lors qu'on
mobilisait les forces nécessaires et que
baisser les bras sur un territoire aussi
petit n'avait pas de sens du côté des
citoyens là encore la satisfaction n'est
pas totale regardez ce que dit le
président du Collectif des citoyens de
Mayotte Fatiou Ibrahim aujourd'hui tout
le monde a l'impression que l'opération
est terminée il existe un goût
d'inachevé les caillassages des forces
de l'ordre ont repris les violences
commencent à remonter progressivement
néanmoins dans les faits l'opération
wambouchou n'est pas terminée elle va se
prolonger jusqu'à la fin de l'année mais
de manière intermittente sur certaines
périodes tan Mohamed swalii est-ce que
vous vous êtes satisfait par les
premiers résultats de cette opération
euh comme l'a souligné faat ibrahimou
euh la violence reprend des bandes de
jeunes qui terrorisent la population qui
se téléphonent qui se donnent des
messages par les réseaux sociaux et qui
vont de village en village incendier des
véhicules incendi des des habitations et
ces bandes de jeunes euh se est en train
de ser la terreur actuellement je dis ça
parce que l'opération bouchou à ce que
c'était le début de quelque chose est un
succès est un succès maintenant il faut
que cette opération et en tout cas la
réponse contre la violence à Mayotte
s'adapte parce que les voyou eux
s'adaptent et évite les les forces de
l'ordre donc l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement de continuer parce qu'il y
a encore des bidonvillees à détruire
parce qu'il y a encore des bandes à à
arrêter et il faut s'adapter et euh euh
harceler harceler ces bandes euh comme
la plupart sont des jeunes il faut aussi
remonter à à à leur famillees on sait
les communes dans les communes nous
savons où c'est où ces jeunes se
réfugient et moi j'appelle à ce que dans
la continuité de cette opération on
s'adapte à ce changement euh si je pu
dire stratégique des voyou donc
s'adapter ça veut dire des moyens en
terme de force de l'ordre supplémentaire
à long terme de manière pérenne et pas
juste sur une opération alors
actuellement il y a une il y a des
forces de l'ordre supplémentair même si
elles ont diminué diminué récemment euh
c'est les deux c'est les deux accroître
les moyens et puis euh ne pas se
contenter c'est ce que rapporte les les
les habitants des des villages euh
lorsque ces ces bandes de jeunes se
visent dans dans les du village ajouter
du du lacrymogène du gaz lacrymogène ce
gaz lacrymogène indispose les enfants et
les personnes vulnérable et ça ne peut
pas être une réponse suffisante pour
disperser et arrêter ces bandes de voyou
c'est-à-dire il faut un armement plus
lourd enfin qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous envisagez euh en tout cas jeter de
lacrimogène je crois que vous en
convenez ce n'est pas une solution une
réponse plus ferme différente doctrine
quoi une réponse exactement une
différence une différente doctrine euh
une réponse qui consiste à les traquer
et à les poursuivre jusque là où ils
vont se se réfugier ce ne sont pas des
des des des voyou qui s'envolent qui qui
qui qui quitte maot du jour au lendemain
il reste sur le territoire et moi ce que
je demande j'un appelle aux forces de
l'ordre qui font un travail euh
difficile et et qui font un gros travail
et bien de de de s'adapter à à ce que
ces ces jeunes sont en train de de faire
Alex sur l'immigration clandestine oui
on voit les expulsions euh s'accélèrent
est-ce que selon vous cette opération a
porté ses fruits les les expulsion euh
s'accélère mais en la matière on peut
difficilement euh encore euh tirer un
satisfa site parce que chaque année ces
25000 à 30000 reconduites à la frontière
à partir de Mayotte plus de la moitié
des reconduites de toute la la France et
euh nous restons sur ces schémas il y a
euh le besoin de reconduire à la
frontière il y a surtout le besoin de
faire en sorte que ces individus ne
reviennent pas parce que si c'est les
mêmes ou quasiment les mêmes qu'on
reconduit vous voyez bien que le le
résultat devient devientourdi revienent
aujourd'hui euh de moins en moins
reviennent mais il y en a encore qui
reviennent il y a des cissas qui
débarquent euh à longueur de de de
semaine et c'est ce ce flux vers le
retour qu'il faut euh arrêter euh en
même temps que la poursuite et
l'intensification des reconduites à la
frontière est-ce que le gouvernement des
Comores des îles les Comores voisines
est plus coopérative justement pour
accepter leurs ressortissants qui sont
expulsés de manière générale le le
gouvernement comorien n'est pas n'est
pas coopératif sans une certaine
pression quelle que soit la nature de
cette pression et là aussi ce qu'il faut
arver à à obtenir c'est que en tout cas
cette pression soit permanente c'est
c'est discussion euh avec le
gouvernement comorien pour qu'il assume
ses responsabilités soit maintenu les
fort soit maintenue toute toute l'année
mais elle est suffisante aujourd'hui
cette pression moi je je dirais qu'elle
n'est pas suffisante tant qu'il y a
autant de flux migratoire on ne peut pas
là aussi euh tirer un satisfaite tant
qu'il y a autant de migrants qui
viennent vers Mayot parce que euh c'est
non seulement des des des migrants
comoriens mais des migrants issus aussi
de l'Afrique continentale passent par
les Comor parce qu'ils savent que c'est
une passoire c'est cette pression just
ça doit s'exercer de quelle manière sur
les visas sur les avoirs des dirigeants
Comoriens qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire sur
tout ça si la simple discussion la
simple coopération conformément à
l'accord qui a été signé en 2019 n'est
pas respecté effectivement et sauf
qu'ils ont été très durs les dirigeants
des Commores au moment du du lancement
de l'opération wambouou est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui ça se passe mieux
aujourd'hui les les et les reconduites
ont repris leur rythme normal le début
de l'opération bouchou a été passionné
il y a eu des des fuites dans la presse
des des exagérations des des des
inexactitudes c'est comme ça que que
beaucoup de de
personnes a réagi de façon négative
maintenant les choses reprennent leur
leur rythme et il faut intensifier parce
que je pense que les incompréhensions
ont été dissipées sur la lutte contre le
logement insalubre on voit voit
l'objectif de destruction des cases de
bidonville n'a pas été totalement
atteint avec ce problème qui est pointé
he il n'y a pas assez de solution de
relogement sur le terrain pour les
personnes qui et bien subissent ces
destructions vous le confirmez c'est un
peu le serpint qui se m à la queue parce
qu'on a besoin de ces terrains inoccupés
occupés illégalement pour en parti
reconstruire moi je pense que l'accent
doit être mis sur la destruction de ces
bidonville il y a des tentatives de de
solution de de relogement il faut aller
euh le plus loin possible mais ce sont
euh des des bidon villes qui sont
insalubres qui sont insécures euh des
gens meurent dans ces ces bidon villes
pendant les saisons de de de pluie donc
même si le le le relogement n'est pas
tout à fait satisfaisant il faut mettre
l'accent sur la destruction de ces bid
au ville est-ce que l'aspect social il a
été insuffisamment traité dans cette
opération mambouchou
quel aspect social l'aspect social qui
doit préoccuper à Mayotte c'est l'aspect
social à l'égard des citoyens Maoré
lorsqu'on sait que Mayotte 77 % de la
population vit en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté excusez-moi mais moi c'est ma
priorité l'autre aspect social d'une
autre partie de la population comme je
l'ai toujours dit c'est au gouvernement
des Comores de s'occuper de sa
population on va continuer à parler de
l'actualité à Mayot le temps de
remercier Alex à tout à l'heure Alex
dans le club on parlera de engagement
des maires ce sera à suivre
effectivement dans le club on va aller à
Mayotte à Kungu retrouver Anne perzo la
fond bonjour Anne merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous rédactrice en chef du journal
de Mayotte Anne avec vous on va parler
d'un autre sujet qui préoccupe les
maorés c'est la crise de l'eau et c'est
aujourd'hui que doit que doit débuter
l'opération de distribution à grande
échelle de bouteille
d'eau bonjour et merci de m'avoir
convier euh oui c'est aujourd'hui le
jour J de la distribution des bouteilles
d'eau à toute la population de Mayotte
euh en fait donc vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que Mayotte a subi une crise de
l'eau euh c'est-à-dire que notre
consommation qui est habituellement de
48 1000 m³ par jour euh n'est plus
assuré par une production suffisante euh
la production ici vient majoritairement
des deux retenues cinaires donc ce sont
des gros lacs de rétention d'eau et de
du captage en rivière et également de
forrage et également de désalinisation
dans une une moindre mesure de de l'eau
de mer euh parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
assez d'investissement de de pratiquer
par le Syndicat des eau dans les dans
les précédente dans la précédente
mandature parce que l'État a manqué de
vigilance et et d'anticipation et parce
que la pluviométrie euh s mise de la
partie avec un déficit
grtérique conséquent euh il n'y a pas eu
de production suffisante depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois on n' pas
cessé d'avoir des coupures depuis 1 an
maintenant à des degrés diverses il a
donc fallu euh ramener cette
consommation euh la réduire le plus
possible donc on a eu des coupure
progressive et maintenant nous sommes en
coupure de 54 heur d'affilé d'eau donc
ça veut dire qu'en fait pendant 54h
d'affilé il n'y a plus d'eau qui coule
au robinet et et après il y a une remise
en eau euh à 16h l'après-midi jusqu'à
10h le lendemain matin donc euh bah
c'est le lapse de temps pour euh
reconstituer les stocks d'eau dans les
famillees dans les foyers c'est très
compliqué notamment en période de
reprise du covid d'un variant ici
également à maillot et donc avec les les
les les les impacts sanitaires que ça
peut avoir voilà donc euh là depuis le 2
septembre il y avait une distribution
d'eau au plus défavorisé les femmes
enceintes les personnes âgées et cetera
donc ça touchait à peu près 60 personnes
60000 pardon personnes vulnérables et
euh notamment les deux scén
Mohamed et Omar W ont été voir la
première ministre qui s'est engagé à une
distribution à toute la population à
partir de ce 20 novembre donc c'est
aujourd'hui que environ
320000 litres d'eau sont distribué au
320000 habitants de Mayotte avec une
logistique incroyable le le préfet de
l'eau Gilles Cantal ici parce qu'un
préfet a été nommé ici SP pour
spécialement pour ce cette crise de
l'eau dit que c'est une logisttique du
jamais vu donc les communes ont été
obligé de s'organiser elles ont l'appui
de à peu près 180 militaires de la
sécurité civile et des pompiers et et
tout ça pour distribuer l'eau à toute la
population dans à peu près 25 points
déterminés sur l'ensemble de l'île donc
c'est c'est un espèce de parif fou c'est
du jamais vu et euh et donc ben en fait
le préfet de l'au a dit on va faire le
bilan au bout d'une semaine euh pour
voir voir comment recaler et o dans
quelle commune ça se passe bien et quel
est quelles sont les communes qui ont
besoin de du plus de plus d'appui euh
parallèlement à cela il y a des pardon
oui non pardon parce que vous je je
crois que vous avez des des questions
pour pour le sénateur
oui voilà alors en fait je voulais aussi
dire que parallèlement il y a il y a
quand même des travaux de fait pour à la
fin du mois avoir 7 les 7000 m cbes qui
manquent pour rattraper en production la
consommation quand même actuelle c'est
ce que je voulais dire et que le
ministre Vigier avait dit à quelques
jours près ça va passer et on est dans
cet instant- là là c'est ce que je
voulais dire et donc en fait cette
distribution des des
320000 l 330000 l par jour euh ma
question c'était est-ce que c'est pas
une distribution symbolique parce que
justement et ça rejoint votre débat sur
l'immigration et sur euh bah faire du
social mais auprès de qui est-ce que
c'est pas une distribution symbolique
justement pour dire ben à toute la
population euh ben voilà là on pense à
tout le monde en fait
alors la la distribution
et on peut dire qu'elle est qu' qu'elle
est symbolique là c'est c'est un sujet
sur lequel il n'y a pas de calcul à
faire euh sans eau on on on ne vit pas
euh c'est
euh un début de distribution à toute la
population les parlementaires de Mayotte
et les élus Maoris nous avons insisté
pour que
cela soit le cas dans le le texte de fin
de gestion la loi de finances de fin de
gestion qui va être votée au Sénat
bientôt il y a 63 millions d'euros
budgetés par l'État pour ce ce sujet de
l'eau de la distribution de des
bouteilles oui c'est symbolique mais
a--on le choix je pense que
c'est un sujet sur lequel il n'y a pas
d'hésitation à avoir Anne vous avez une
autre
question ben non non en fait je c'est
c'est plus une remarque de dire que
cette distribution elle est aussi
nécessaire
pour de cette cette ampleur là parce que
c'est lié justement à l'immigration et
en fait c'est c'est aussi pour dire que
Mayotte quelque part fait de
l'humanitaire encore une fois à
destination de la population de
l'entièreté des commor quoi en fait et
donc on devrait avoir des budgets
humanitaires qui correspond à ça parce
que que ce soit les soins la scolarité
ou là l'eau en fait c'est de
l'humanitaire pour l'archipel des
Comores je sais pas si le sénateur est
d'accord avec moi je suis d'accord sur
le constat maintenant sur la réaction
qu'il faut avoir face à cela
euh l'enjeu ce n'est pas de faire en
sorte que cette population en situation
irrégulière reste à Mayotte donc on
revient sur la coopération avec les
commor ce qu'il faut faire c'est faire
en sorte que euh les infrastructures et
notamment euh les les écoles soient
construites au Comor et pour que cette
population reste fixée chez elle un
dernier mot sur cette cette distribution
de bouteill d'eau Anne l'a dit ce sont
des dizaines de milliers de bouteilles
d'eau qui vont être distribué est-ce
qu'il y a la crainte d'une pollution
plastique à grande échelle derrière oui
et sur ce sur le sujet je pense que nous
allons anticiper j'en ai parlé avec le
le président du syndicat de de ramassage
des déchets et l'idée serait d'utiliser
les containeur qui au lieu de repartir à
vide repartent avec ses Boutiers ses
bouteilles pardon vided pour que elle
soit traitée ailleurs dans d'autres donc
ça ça se place merci merci Anne perzol
fond merci infiniment d'avoir été avec
nous depuis maotte pour nous parler de
ce problème évidemment très important
pour l'île merci Anne perzo la fond
d'avoir été avec
nous un dernier un dernier mot
rapidement tan Mohamed swali puisque
s'ouvre aujourd'hui le Congrès des m par
la traditionnelle journée consacrée aux
élus des outr-mères qu'est-ce que vous
attendez du gouvernement est-ce que les
spécificités des outr-mères sont
suffisamment prise en compte les les
spécificités des des outremires
euh gagneri gagne à être mieux prise en
compte même s'il faut souligner les les
efforts qui qui sont qui sont faits
c'est l'occasion euh pour ces maires de
venir je veux dire en direct euh dire
les chose avec l'appui de l'Association
des maires qui fait euh un gros travail
l'année dernière nous avons inauguré la
délégation aux autres maires au sein de
l'Association des Maires et là les
maires viennent quelque part en appui de
ce que les parlementaires font au
quotidien c'est-à-dire faire entendre
leur voix directement ici à Paris merci
merci beaucoup Tanny Mohamed swali
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin